c'est très symbolique quand on passe ce
portail on est coupé du monde
cela vraiment
une réalité concrète des choses pour
fait de faire un projet là dessus sans
vraiment impliqué c'est important de
savoir ce qui s'est passé avant que ça
se reproduise on sera plus qu ils ont
vécu non pas les oublier au final
[Musique]
comment se fait il qu'un jeune sur cinq
n'est pas entendu aujourd'hui parler de
la shoah
ce n'est pas un problème de terminologie
car le génocide des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale ne leur évoque
rien non plus la question interroge
dérange peut-être sans doute n'at-on pas
suffisamment bien enseigner la shoah
fait ici au lycée charles de gaulle
personne ne peut se faire ce reproche
chers élèves cher professeur
merci poursuivez votre engagement
incarnant et défendant les valeurs
républicaines
un engagement une application très forte
reconduite d'année en année autour d'un
projet pédagogique sur la shoah et qui
invariablement au moment de la
restitution du travail des élèves se
termine par cette cérémonie en présence
des représentants de l'état et des
associations de lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et le racisme
nous apprenons ce qu'est le devoir de
mémoire qui est essentiel à la
compréhension de l'histoire
nous sommes beaucoup à apprendre mais
très peu à comprendre nous n'avons pas
vu la shoah nous avons regardé une page
de notre histoire de même que nous
n'avons pas entendu ce témoignage nous
les avons écoutés
maintenant on peut vraiment avoir un
regard très particulier sur les
événements qui se passe aujourd'hui et
on peut faire un parallèle sur ce qui
s'est passé avant et m'a pris pour finir
ce travail ne nous permettra pas de
comprendre comment des hommes ont-ils pu
planifier la déshumanisation ainsi que
programmé la mort d'une population
entière
pour autant le fait de s'imprégner de
l'atmosphère angoissante de ces lieux
ainsi que la vue directe des preuves du
génocide permet de faire face au bar à
paris ce jeu très impressionné par leur
projet par l'ampleur d'aller jusqu'au
voyage jusque jusqu'en pologne je pense
que ça a été un voyage très important
pour eux et dont ils vont souvenir
longtemps ils sont revenus
marc est différent je pense que c'est
aussi un quelque chose qui a été
important par rapport à l'acquisition
d'une certaine maturité
il ya des choses maintenant qu'ils sont
certainement plus clair dans leur esprit
et puis une certaine ouverture aussi sur
les difficultés du monde actuel et
peut-être ça éveille aussi une certaine
vigilance et
ici en tout cas de tout ça dont on a pu
reparler ensemble la liberté est fragile
ces jeunes en sont conscients et ils
savent désormais que chacun d'entre nous
est responsable de la sauvegarde des
valeurs humaines et de l'humanité elle
même
ils comprennent d'autant plus
l'inquiétude de la présidente du comité
français de yad vashem
je le demande et je ne pensais pas
pouvoir me le demande et si un jour mes
enfants et mes petits enfants pourront
continuer à vivre libre et paisible dans
leur patrie maintenant moi j'ai peur
pour la france
faites attention aux signes avant
coureurs vaste sujet de préoccupation
aujourd'hui le déferlement de la haine
raciste et antisémite sur internet
je ne sais pas si vous allez sur les
réseaux sociaux mais moi je regarde un
peu et est franchement j'suis épouvanté
ça signifie aussi que nous peut être
avec nous avons failli à notre rôle
éducatif et donc il faut il faut
effectivement
redresser cela rend tous les cas
combattre cela et c'est bien l'objectif
de dimitri vous elle professeur
d'histoire géographie qui chaque année
trouve un nouveau thème pour faire
travailler ses élèves sur la chose on
souhaite continuer c'est possible dans
les années à venir monter d'autres
projets avec d'autres élèves pour
continuer l'éducation
à l'altérité l'éducation également à la
tolérance qui est un peu plus
fondamentale entre société au 28 août
c'est en 2019
le projet pédagogique de l'année
précédente a reçu le prix annie et
charles corps à un prix national qui
soutient toute action éducative
entreprises pour que les jeunes
générations garde vivante la mémoire de
la shoah
[Musique]